hallo mein name ist luca und vor
dreieinhalb jahren habe ich das letzte
mal happy meals auf meinem kanal
gespielt das ist seine wirbelsäule und
heute spielen wir wieder mal happy meals
weil ich sage ich einfach mal auf play
und wir wollen uns hier irgendeinen
level aus beispielsweise bmx park und
das spielen wir jetzt mal hier sind
dieser familienvater auf dem fahrrad mit
seinem sohn auf dem rücksitz und wir
fahren jetzt einfach mal ein kleines
stückchen vor dem das ding rein und
durch die halfpipe und nach oben
und jetzt so weiter und jetzt hier und
jetzt sind wir auf der seite
also wir fahren hier direkt runter
fahren hier durch diese haft halb durch
okay wir leben noch weiter geht es von
daher nichts passierte so nah zwar
unserer seinen helm verloren aber weiter
hier vorne lang genau jetzt hier wieder
über die halfpipe darüber hier wieder
runter das ist eigentlich recht
wir leben noch alles gut
wir leben wird sind wir leben doch okay
wir haben sollen fordert aber das ist
egal hauptsache wir leben noch
ich fahre ich oh mein gott ich lebe ich
fahre noch ich ja super level das tun an
dem spiel happy willst es allerdings
dass wir nicht in diesem level quasi
gefangen sind die ganze zeit sondern wir
können uns jetzt ein anderes level
heraussuchen beispielsweise balcony
terror hört sich doch vernünftig an in
diesem level können uns jetzt sogar den
charakter selbst aussuchen von daher
würde ich sagen nehme ich einfach mal
den opa in seinem komischen privat
helikopter ding also los geht die lutzi
hirt sack fliegen wir hier oben drüber
und
wo bin ich
neustart also ich glaube wir müssen hier
vorne runter und damit hier das ist
schwieriger als aussieht es ist
schwieriger als es aussieht das ist mein
herz was da auf der frau liegt und jetzt
auf dem dem auto das war mein körper
allerdings müssen wir den happy meals
nicht nur die ganze zeit diese features
level zu spielen sondern wir können hier
auf user level browser klicken und dann
sehen wir schon hier sind levels die
wirklich spieler gemacht haben also
jeder auf der welt kann selbst ein happy
meals level erstellen und ich würde
sagen da wir jetzt einfach mal ganz
zufällig dieses level hieraus europe 1
hat das gemacht und das heißt steht
level von ups also genau das passende
für mich eigentlich als charakter wählen
wir wieder ganz simpel den mann mit
seinem sohn aus und fahren einfach mal
hier hoch ja ich bin mega schnell
allerdings fallen wir jetzt wieder
runter und werden dementsprechend auch
nicht mal ein bisschen schneller genau
fahren wir hier geradeaus weiter fahren
wir hier weiter das war dann auch das
was das bekommt von mir fünf sterne
bevor wir uns allerdings das nächste
level eines willkürlichen happy hills
user spielen möchte ich wieder eine
couch auf instagram pushen und zwar habe
ich mir vorgenommen dass ich in jedem
meiner youtube-videos jemanden von euch
pushen und zwar bis heute der account
laser lucassen limes mit dem foto andere
machen ihren abschluss oder studieren
und ich drücke an türen an denen ziehen
steht fand ich auf jeden fall wird sich
als ich auf dem bild markiert wurde also
wenn ihr auch ein ins remscheider in
meinem nächsten youtube-video haben
wollt dann markiert laser luca auf euren
bildern auf irgendwelchen - mit meinem
gesicht fan arzt was auch immer und
vielleicht werdet ihr dann im nächsten
video geputscht genauso wie laser lukas
teams also folgt dem acker und gern
machen wir nun allerdings weiter mit dem
nächsten user generated level und zwar
würde ich sagen machen einfach mal dass
hier profis heißt dass das hier ist
nämlich der popo stick mann und ich kann
einfach space gerückt hatten dann hoch
springen und dann
[Musik]
habe ich eine lanze im popo noch stecken
hammer level 5 von 5 sternen bekommst du
auf jeden fall von mir auch immer was
wir noch so für levels haben dass ihr
hat sogar fünf sterne bekommen wurde
schon 700 mal gespielt also das muss
eigentlich gut sein
ich bin der segway und fahren nach vorne
und fahren weiter nach vorne und
ich habe mich auch schon gefragt wo mein
kopf ist wichtig einfach mal auf restart
level ich weiß ja irgendwie was falsch
gemacht habe die karte explodiert auf
jeden fall direkt ich fahre ganz normal
durch und ok
daran will ich vorbei ich bin ich wer
ich bin
ich bin vom boden aufgefressen worden
jedoch würde ich sagen geben wir jetzt
einfach mal bei der suche hier luca ein
weil man kann auch nach namen suchen und
das hier sind alles wenn wir mit dem
namen luca im titel oder über die sagen
wenn ich direkt das erste level aus das
heißt einfach nur luca und der kommentar
des stelle arztes levels ist auch
einfach nur luca also klickt man auf
play now ich nehme einfach den typisch
[Musik]
was muss ich hier tun 2000 jahre später
das war ja auch einen super level jetzt
soll das nächste level mit dem namen
luca anders heißt luca toni drache
playnow und ich muss einfach losfahren
hey familienausflug ich mit meinen
beiden kindern hier fahren wir schöne
treppe okay jeder lebt noch die kleine
trampelt so schnell sie kann mädels wir
fahren ja das kind mochte ich eh nicht
so gerne fahre ich auch direkt nochmal
drüber
[Musik]
na hauptsache die kleine troubled noch
genauso haben wir hier bei gebracht also
dass auch hier ein super level x10 mini
und spielen das nächste der wir mit dem
namen luca dass ich kann nicht vorfahren
ich kann nicht zurückfahren ich kann
doch nicht richtig springen habe ich
kann loslassen am segway und
ja aber levels mit meinem namen wenn ihr
selbst denkt hey das sind ja alles voll
die kacke levels ich selbst kann das
viel besser als luca soll mal mein level
im nächsten video happy juli spielen
werde darauf über bock habt lasst den
daumen hoch da unter dem video aber dann
könnt ihr auf jeden fall auch einfach in
hegels gehen und einfach in level
erstellen
ich bin fette sau auf dem roller und
also clan richtig neues projekt ist es
jetzt natürlich nicht ich habe früher
vor ein paar jahren haben wir jetzt mit
jenen der einwendung gesehen habt schon
mal happy meals gespielt ich es geht los
und meine kinder direkt eine axt im
gesicht was ich gerade sagen wollte ich
hab natürlich früher schnäppchen wie 10
spielt mein sohn ist mittlerweile super
aber nur uns interessiert uns wirklich
sitte wir sind wollt ihr mich verarschen
wenn ihr bock auf mehr hätte wills habe
wie bereits gesagt last night bei dem
video da schreibst du gerne in die
kommentare wir wählen mal das leveln als
nächstes aus wir nehmen den opa hier mit
seinen komischen teilnahmen dimitrow
[Musik]
wir machen das ganze jetzt mal anders
und zwar sortiere ich die levels nach
dem playground also der 24 24.000 leute
haben dieses level mit dem namen lukas
op 2 gespielt das heißt wir blicken
jetzt einfach mal auf play now ist muss
gut sein dass leute haben 24.000 leute
gespielt und ein fallstrick
[Musik]
wir starten das mal neun ich fahre
diesmal in die richtige richtung also ab
nach vorne fahren hier der vater mit
seinem sohn wieder hier vorne lang und
jetzt hier
[Musik]
24.000 leute haben das gespielt aber gut
spielen mal das nächste level das hat
nämlich auch 20.000 place einem klick
hier einfach mal auf planes ist wieder
vater mit seiner blauen strecke geben
vollgas hier vorne lang genau und wir
werden immer schneller und wir sind
schnell und hier sind wir müssen wir
müssen
[Musik]
bild max and many und schauen uns direkt
das nächste level an das hat tatsächlich
eine viereinhalb sterne bewertung
das muss gut sein soll los geht's am ich
muss leute umbringen mit den messern
[Musik]
dass dinge ist dass das hier ja alles
nur levels sind die wirklich luca heiß
und die meisten kommen dagegen aus
spanien italien whatever
das heißt ich gebe jetzt einfach mal
laser luca ein und
[Musik]
leute ihr müsst mit levels magen macht
gern happy meals levels mit dem namen
laser luca und dann spiele ich die
vielleicht im nächsten video aber wir
könnten theoretisch mal kontra ftr 1
geben weil ich glaube früher habe ich
immer gesagt wir sollten die levels
machen mit dem titel kontraste haha da
wird 2012 von crafter dass das kann ich
nicht spielen kann ich werbe freundlich
von neuville ich sagen ich mir das
zweite spiel hier bzw zweite level
contractor race heißt das nicht sehr
lang aber egal der spielspaß ist wichtig
ich hoffe es gefällt dir also spiel los
geht's konkret muss ich ja auch
muss ich hier auch irgendwas steuern
oder chili war
nur ich bin ich kann mich irgendwie ich
musste doch hier
[Musik]
ich glaube das wird nichts weil meine
damen und herren allerdings würde ich an
anderer stelle durch das heutige happy
meals video jetzt auf jeden fall auch
beendet meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat das einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier dauert bei 50.000
likes kommt nächste woche eine neue
folge happy meals macht gern level mit
dem namen laser luca benennen dann
spiele ich die eventuell im nächsten
video und werden ihren instagram
showdown haben wollt dann markierte luuk
auf euren instagram bildern abonniert
zudem gerne einen kanal falls sie noch
kein teil der linken seite verpasste das
nächste video nicht und das kann ich
noch so alles sagen aber ich habe auch
einen shop
[Musik]